monsieur ramirez n'était pas en état
d'arrestation
on a pourtant empêché de se rendre au
petit coin en violation de ses droits
civils avant de ré ce poids lors du
procès mais j'aimerais aborder
maintenant israël
je vais vous condamné pour outrage si
vous poursuivez dans cette voie vous me
demander de me conformer à une décision
erronée de temporiser je ne partage pas
voilà outrage au tribunal
cette étude est en déficit depuis des
années mon vieux
vous étiez une pierre angulaire de
l'activisme une source d'actionnaires
c'est de faire l'impossible sans
rétribution
il faudra gagner sa vie
prenez soin niveau surtout je sais je
sais plus combien un paquet tout ce qu
on va se dire sera strictement
confidentielles le type qui a fait ça je
sais où il est je veux la récompense en
liquide
le monde est plein de choses
merveilleuses qu'est ce que vous en
dites je peux emménager quand une source
fiable km à prendre un truc sur vous
vous saviez ont trouvé bien j'aurai vote
pour le fort le petit roy revient
romain vous avez enfreint la loi ils
sont dangereux ils veulent votre marque
c'est trop tard vous ne pouvez pas vous
défilez je me défilerai pas
je veux en finir avec ça
on est tous plus grand que lapierre
chose qu'on m'ait jamais fait